et ont rejoint notre correspondant à
kiev gulliver crack bonjour aux éleveurs
la russie semble donc désormais se
concentrer sur les villes de ce la
viande ce qui est de cramât torse qu un
peu plus à l'ouest
oui ce sont les deux villes principales
dans la région de thoune est que qui
reste sous contrôle l'ukrainien qui sont
depuis des semaines maintenant déjà
ciblé par les attaques tout porte à
croire que maintenant ces attaques vont
s'intensifier puisque le but affiché des
russes est de prendre le contrôle de la
totalité de la région de donetsk aussi
est même peut-être au-delà on les entend
beaucoup moins souvent maintenant fait
affirmer qu'ils vont se limiter à la
conquête de la seule région d'une baston
que l'inquiétude est très grande en
ukraine en ce moment est d'autant plus
que même si les ukrainiens veulent
caractériser ce retrait de licite
chances que la dernière visite de la
région de loin de ce que d'huile se sont
retirés comme un retrait tactique le
président volodymyr zelensky promet que
l'ukraine reviendra et reconquérir à ces
territoires ils ont dit aussi très
franchement que l'une des raisons
principales de ce retrait c'est tout
simplement la supériorité de
l'artillerie russe en terme de la
quantité des missiles et d'obus qu'ils
sont capables d'envoyer l'ukraine n'a
pas assez de munitions en ce moment le
pays attend désespérément je pense que
c'est le cas de le dire les livraisons
d'armes supplémentaires de ses alliées
occidentales
et si les forces du craignent elles se
sont retirées de licite chance c'est en
partie l hiver pour éviter un scénario à
la marioupol qui s'était sur l'idée on
se rappelle par la capture de 2500
combattants ukrainien quelle nouvelle
d'ailleurs de ces prisonniers de guerre
exactement c'était ça aussi la grande
raison qui étaient donnés les ukrainiens
voulu se retirer avant d'être auxerre
qui encerclaient comme il l'avait été à
marioupol il y a eu 95 soldats qui sont
prisonniers russes qui ont été libérés
la semaine dernière dans un échange de
prisonniers 95 parmi les défenseurs de
marioupol mais ça laisse un peu plus de
2400 qui sont toujours en captivité je
viens d'assister à cette conférence de
presse de leurs proches qui disent
qu'ils n'ont aucun accès à ces
prisonniers et il dénonce une violation
très sévère des conventions de genève
ils n'ont pas du tout informés sur leur
état de santé ni même pour beaucoup
d'entre eux sur la location où ils sont
détenus et ils disent que l'ukraine
adhère aux règles des conventions de
genève et donne accès aux familles
russes des prisonniers russes que
l'ukraine détient et ils nous veulent
absolument attirer l'attention sur ce
qu'ils estiment être une injustice très
grande à ce manque d'accès à ce mode de
communication avec les prisonniers merci
beaucoup d'univers pour toutes vos
précisions depuis kiev